WHETHER WE EVEN NEED ONE,
AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: LET’S BRING IN, BRIAN,
AND STEVE LET’S BRING IN SARAH
SANDERS, FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY, GOOD MORNING TO
YOU, SARAH.
SARAH: GOOD MORNING, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON.
AINSLEY: WE HAD THE TOWN HALL,
BRET AND MARTHA DID A GREAT JOB
INTERVIEWING THE PRESIDENT AT
THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL, MANY OF US
ARE SCARED THAT WE WILL GET IT
AND MANY ARE SCARED OF LOSING
OUR JOBS AND WATCHING THE
ECONOMY CRUMBLE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> YOU CAN SATISFY BOTH. YOU’RE
SCARED YOU’RE GOING TO STAY BACK
A LITTLE BIT AND WATCH IT BUT
THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE SCARED IN
LOCKED IN A ROOM AND LOSING
THEIR JOB AND NOT HAVING ANY
INCOME AND FOR THE FIRST TIME,
THESE ARE WORKERS AND PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO GET BACK TO WORK
AND MAKE A LIVING AND THEY’RE
AFRAID THAT THEIR JOB IS GOING
TO BE THERE.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT VERY WELL.
AINSLEY: WHAT’S YOUR REACTION?
SARAH: I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
EXACTLY RIGHT, THAT HE HAS A
DIFFICULT JOB IN FINDING THAT
PERFECT BALANCE.
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT
AMERICAN LIVES WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME PROTECTING AMERICAN
LIVELIHOOD.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN
THE RIGHT APPROACH IN ALLOWING
STATES TO HAVE A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY AND MAKING DECISIONS
THAT ARE THE BEST FOR THOSE
STATES.
I THINK MAYORS BEING EMPOWERED
ARE ALSO A GOOD THING BECAUSE
WHAT WORKS IN ARKANSAS ISN’T
NECESSARILY GOING TO BE WHAT
WORKS IN NEW JERSEY.
I THINK THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS TAKEN THE RIGHT APPROACH IN
PROVIDING RESOURCES AND THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW STATES TO
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
AS YOU GUYS TALKED ABOUT, THERE
ARE A LOT OF STATES THAT ARE
MAKING SOME STEPS TODAY TO START
THE REOPENING PROCESS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE THE TYPE
OF PEOPLE THAT WANT TO WORK,
THEY WANT TO GO OUT AND DO THEIR
PART AND A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
KIND OF THAT MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL HEALTH TIED TO WORKING
AND THEY WANT TO GET BACK OUT
THERE AND I THINK THAT IF
THEY’RE IN A PLACE AND THEIR
WORKPLACE CAN ALLOW THEM TO
SAFELY RETURN, THAT’S A GOOD
THING FOR A LOT OF AMERICANS.
THOSE THAT ARE MOST VULNERABLE
STILL HAVE TO TAKE RECAUTIONS --
PRECAUTIONS AND MAKE SURE THEY
ARE FOLLOWING GUIDELINES.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, SARAH,
EVERYBODY IS EXCITED ABOUT
REOPENING THE COUNTRY FOR
BUSINESS, BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THE DOOR MAY BE OPEN, BUT THE
QUESTION IS, WHEN WILL THE
PEOPLE COME IN.
AS THE PEOPLE AT THE BUSINESS
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO RUN AND
OPERATE AT A SAFE DISTANCE AND
THINGS LIKE THAT, THEN THERE’S
GOT TO BE CONFIDENCE IN THE
PUBLIC THAT WHEN I WALK IN THE
PLACE I’M GOING TO BE SAFE AND I
THINK THAT -- I DON’T KNOW IF
THAT HAPPENS TODAY OR IF IT
TAKES A LITTLE TIME.
SARAH: AGAIN, THIS IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS SO DIFFICULT
ABOUT THE PROCESS.
IT’S UNPRECEDENTED AND SOMETHING
NONE OF US HAVE BEEN THROUGH
BEFORE AND BUSINESSES ARE GOING
THE EXTRA MILE TRYING TO
REASSURE THE CUSTOMERS, PROCESS
THAT IS -- PROCESSES THAT THEY
HAVE PUT IN PLACE ALLOWING
CURBSIDE PICKUP HAVE HELPED A
LOT AND I THINK WE WILL CONTINUE
TO SEE THAT -- MAYBE THAT
BECOMES THE NEW NORMAL.
HOPEFULLY OVER THE COURSE OF
NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS WE CAN GET
BACK TO WHERE GROUP GATHERINGS
SOMETHING THAT WE GET TO DO
AGAIN.
SOME PEOPLE IN OUR HOUSEHOLD ARE
READY TO SEE FRIENDS AND FAMILY
ON A REGULAR BASIS AGAIN.
BRIAN: SARAH, I DON’T WANT TO
THINK POLITICS IS PLAYING A ROLE
BUT IT’S HARD NOT TO SEE WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN MICHIGAN, SEEING
THE OUTRAGE AND SLOW ROLLOUT AND
WONDER IF THE DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR, DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR OF
MAINE AND THE DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA ARE
CREATING OUTRAGE BECAUSE OF THE
CITIZENS ARE SEEING THEY NEED A
FASTER PACE WITH THE ROLLOUT AND
I HOPE THE DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS
ARE GOING I’M NO NO RUSH TO TURN
THE ECONOMY AROUND FOR THE
PRESIDENT, DO YOU FEAR THAT OR
AM I OVERTHINKING IT?
SARAH: LOOK, I THINK THE
GOVERNORS ARE TRYING TO MAKE THE
BEST DECISIONS THEY CAN BUT
ULTIMATELY THEY HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT THEY HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
THE PEOPLE OF THEIR STATE TO
ALLOW THEM TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND IF EVERYONE ELSE --
AND THEY GET TO A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN SAFELY DO THAT THEY
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO AT SOME
POINT ALLOW THAT TO TAKE PLACE.
I THINK WE NEED TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT, THE RESOURCES AND I
THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE
EXACTLY THE RIGHT THING IN
PROVIDING THAT FLEXIBILITY,
PROVIDING FINANCIAL RESOURCES
FOR STATES AND IN TERMS OF
SUPPLIES SO THAT THEY CAN DO
THAT AND CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND
HOPEFULLY THE GOVERNORS WILL
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION TO DO
WHAT’S BEST FOR THE PEOPLE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES, BOTH
PROTECTING THEIR HEALTH AND
PROTECTING THEIR ECONOMIES
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THOSE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
VOTED FOR AS WELL.
THEY’LL EITHER GET TO KEEP THEIR
JOBS OR NOT BECAUSE THEY DID THE
RIGHT THING BY THE PEOPLE IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
AINSLEY: THAT’S RIGHT.
SO SARAH, WE’VE ALL HAD TO FIND
WAYS TO TALK TO OUR CHILDREN
ABOUT THIS DEPENDING ON THEIR
AGE WE GIVE THEM SPECIFICS.
MY DAUGHTER IS 4, SHE DOESN’T
REALLY UNDERSTAND THIS BUT --
HOW OLD ARE YOUR KIDS?
>> I HAVE AN 8-YEAR-OLD AND
6-YEAR-OLD AND A 4-YEAR-OLD.
AINSLEY: OKAY, SO THE PRESIDENT
WAS ASKED ABOUT IT HOW HE’S
TELLING HIS SON, HOW HE’S
TALKING TO HIS SON ABOUT IT AND
GRANDKIDS, LISTEN TO HIM.
>> I SAT DOWN WITH MY SON AND I
SAT DOWN WITH MY GRANDCHILDREN
AND I SAID A TERRIBLE THING
THAT’S HAPPENED AND A THING THAT
WE HAVE NEVER EXPERIENCED.
SOMETHING HAPPENED AND WE WILL
BE STRONG AND GET OUT OF IT AND
OUR COUNTRY WILL BE BIGGER AND
BETTER AND STRONGER THAN EVER
BEFORE.
AINSLEY: HOW DID YOU TALK TO
YOUR CHILDREN, SARAH?
SARAH: MUCH IN THE SAME WAY.
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
WE CAN DO IS BE HONEST WITH OUR
KIDS AND TRANSPARENT.
MY KIDS ARE YOUNG SO IT’S HARD
FOR THEM TO PROCESS EVERYTHING
THAT’S GOING ON.
THEY DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
CAN’T GO TO SCHOOL OR WHY THEY
CAN’T PLAY WITH THEIR FRIENDS
EVERY DAY BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE TRIED TO FOCUS ON SOME OF THE
POSITIVE THINGS THAT WE STILL
LIVE IN THE GREATEST COUNTRY ON
THE FACE OF THE PLANET, WE HAVE
A GOD WHO LOVES US AND
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ALL UNDER HIS
CONTROL AND WE GOT TO PEND A LOT
TIME WITH FAMILY.
WE HAVE BEEN HOMESCHOOLING OUR
KIDS AND THAT COULD BE A
DETRIMENT BUT AT THE END TO HAVE
DAY WE TRY TO BE HONEST WITH OUR
KIDS AND IT’S DIFFICULT TO HEAR
YOUR 4-YEAR-OLD PRAY EVERY NIGHT
THAT HE HOPES PHONE GETS KILLED
FROM THE VIRUS BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE TRY TO REINFORCE THAT,
WE HAVE A GOD THAT LOVES US AND
THAT WE ARE STILL IN AMERICA,
RESILIENT AND TOUGH COUNTRY AND
WE WILL COME BACK AND WE WILL
COME BACK STRONGER AND WE ARE
GOING TO DO THAT TOGETHER AS A
FAMILY AND AS A COUNTRY.
STEVE: THAT’S RIGHT, WE ARE IN
THIS TOGETHER.
SARAH, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
FACT THAT OVER THE LAST WEEK OR
SO THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE THE
NIGHTLY 5:00 O’CLOCK OR
6:00 O’CLOCK P.M. PRESS
BRIEFINGS WHERE IT MIGHT GO HALF
HOUR, MIGHT GO TWO HOURS AND
DOES TARGETED BUSINESS EVENTS,
HE HAS GUESTS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND YOU HAD BIG EVENT LAST NIGHT
AT THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL.
IS THAT MORE EFFECTIVE AT
GETTING THE MESSAGE OUT?
I SAW THAT OVER THE LAST 2
WEEKS, I THINK IT WAS GALLUP
SAYS THE PRESIDENT’S RATINGS
HAVE GONE UP 6 POINTS IN TWO
WEEKS?
SARAH: I THINK IT’S GREAT FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO SPEAK TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE DOES THAT IN A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT WAYS.
SOME DAYS IT’S BY TWITTER AND
SOME DAYS BY LINCOLN MEMORIAL
HALL AND I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN ACCESSIBLE AND HE HAS
BEEN UP FRONT AND VOCAL AND
SHOWN HE’S AN ACTUAL LEADER IN
THE TIME OF CRISIS.
HE’S PRESENTED UP IN THE TIME
THAT WE NEEDED HIM THE MOST AND
HE’S BEEN UP FRONT AND CENTER
AND THAT’S BEEN REALLY IMPORTANT
AND WHEN HE NEEDS OTHER PEOPLE
TO COME IN, WHETHER IT’S THE
VICE PRESIDENT, LARRY KUDLOW,
DR. FAUCI AND DR. BIRX AND
OTHERS TO COME FORWARD AND TALK
ABOUT A DIFFERENT MESSAGE, HE’S
DONE THAT.
I THINK HE’S DONE THE RIGHT
THING IN PROVIDING CONSTANT AND
FREQUENT INFORMATION.
I LOVE THE DIFFERENT FORMATS AND
VENUES.
I THINK HE SHOULD CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AND I ALSO THINK KAYLEIGH
MCENANY DID A PHENOMENAL JOB
LAST WEEK IN FIRST PRESS
BRIEFING.
I THINK IT’S A GOOD IDEA TO MIX
THAT UP AND ENGAGE AND SPEAK ON
HIS BEHALF AS WELL.
BRIAN: SARAH, THE NEW YORK CITY
HAD A BRILLIANT IDEA.
THEY THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A GREAT
IDEA FOR DNC TO INVESTIGATE JOE
BIDEN ABOUT THE SEXUAL ASSAULT.
LET’S REALLY GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT.
YOU KNOW THEY WILL DRILL DOWN
DEEP UNTIL THEY GET THE ANSWER.
EVERYBODY IS SAYING, ARE YOU
KIDDING ME.
I THINK I WILL REJECT MY
SUBSCRIPTION AGAIN.
ALSO ADD TO THIS ON THE
ALLEGATION FROM TARA READE, FOX
NEWS HAS LEARNED THAT RONAN
FARRO IS DOING EXTENDED PIECE OF
THE NEW YORKER.
THE LAST THING THE COUNTRY NEEDS
A SEX SCANDAL TO GO THROUGH IT
BUT IT’S NOT OUR CHOICE, WHERE
DO YOU THINK THIS IS READING?
SARAH: LOOK, WHEN YOU FIRST SAID
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAD A GOOD
IDEA I KNEW SOMETHING MUST BE
WRONG.
THE IDEA THAT THE DNC WOULD BE
THE ONE TO TAKE THE LEAD ON ANY
INVESTIGATION INVOLVING ONE OF
THEIR OWN CANDIDATES IS
LAUGHABLE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS AN ONION
HEADLINE AND NOT A NEW YORK
TIMES HEADLINE.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES FOR SUGGESTING THAT
IDEA.
AT THE END OF THE DAY PEOPLE
WANT FAIRNESS AND THE HYPOCRISY
FROM THE LEFT IS TRULY MIND
BLOWING.
THE FACT THAT THEY WENT SO
AGGRESSIVELY AFTER JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH AND DEMANDED TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THINGS BUT WE
WANTED TO BRUSH THIS ASIDE I
THINK IS THE REAL CHALLENGE THAT
MOST PEOPLE ARE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW AND THEY WANT TO SEE A
LEVEL OF FAIRNESS FROM BOTH
SIDES AND THE HYPOCRISY FROM THE
MEDIA AND THE LEFT ON THIS IS
REALLY HARD TO SWALLOW.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD AND PUT THE INFORMATION
OUT THERE AND LET THE
INVESTIGATION GO WHERE IT MAY
AND MAYBE JOE COMES OUT GREAT
AND GOOD FOR HIM IF HE DOES, BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS OF THE
INVESTIGATION AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS AND IT SHOULD BE FAIR ON
BOTH SIDES.
AINSLEY: OKAY, SARAH, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.